nuclear technology
doesn't get great publicity
in blockbuster films it creates
terrifying monsters such as godzilla
and the hulk it's characterized by
incompetence
in cult tv shows like the simpsons
and the hit hbo series chernobyl what
did you do
i did what you said i swear look at it
and it's normally in the news
because something has gone wrong it's an
atomic fire and the soviets can't
contain it
a third explosion at the fukushima power
plant japanese prime minister says
radioactive levels around the plant are
high
but nuclear energy is safe reasonably
reliable
and efficient without it it'll be much
harder to fight climate change
so why does nuclear power still only
make up 10
of global electricity generation
[Music]
[Laughter]
the natural power of the universe is
harnessed in the new atomic bomb
its tremendous possibilities are
explained in 1945
nuclear's full unimaginable power was
demonstrated to the world
eight years later president eisenhower
proposed using nuclear energy
as a way to redeem humankind for having
brought such an awful technology
into existence united states knows that
peaceful power from atomic energy is no
dream of the future that capability
already proved
is here now today
when the nuclear reactors first um open
there's a
there's a big futuristic buzz about them
this is when jet planes are new nuclear
reactors are new
we're short just short of the age of the
satellite so this is very much a symbol
of modernity
and it's also a symbol in some eyes of
peace
in 1956 the world's first commercial
nuclear power station
was opened in britain by the end of the
1960s
78 reactors had been built across 14
countries
[Music]
nuclear reactors generate power through
nuclear fission
a process where uranium atoms are split
and release energy
in the center of an atom is its nucleus
which contains protons
and neutrons in the process of nuclear
fission
one of these nuclei breaks apart
producing smaller nuclei
some neutrons and some energy
if one of the neutrons hits another
nucleus it too will break apart
in what is known as a chain reaction to
ensure the chain reaction takes place at
the right speed
and the power plant doesn't overheat
control rods
made of neutron absorbing materials are
lowered into the reactor
in most reactors they sit in water which
acts as a moderator
slowing down the neutrons and helping
control the rate of the reaction
the energy from the chain reaction
produces a huge amount of heat
which most reactors use to turn water
into steam
nuclear power plants are basically very
large kettles they take water and they
heat it up a lot and then the heated
water the steam
can drive turbines and that's kind of
what a
coal power plant or a gas power plant
does too but nuclear does it very
efficiently and it does it with far less
fuel because uranium has an awful lot of
energy in it whereas coal and gas have
comparatively little
so you can fuel uh a nuclear reactor
with you know tons of fuel rather than
thousands of tons of fuel
um it's it's like an invisible force
isn't it what happens if there is an
accident we've got
we've got no chance and if it's
uncontrollable it's going to
cause some harm in it
so what damaged nuclear power's
reputation
to understand we need to go back to
where we left off in the nuclear boom of
the 1960s
initially some environmentalists were
supporters of nuclear energy
they saw it as an alternative to
flooding values for hydroelectric power
but then they changed their minds for
that warning canterbury one
canterbury two candidates in the 1960s
some people begin to worry that nuclear
power stations
just in their everyday running
will poison the world this is
not remotely true but it becomes part of
a campaign
but the big worry comes um i think in
the early 1970s when people start
worrying that a nuclear accident is in
some ways
like an atomic bomb going off and you've
got to remember there's a
there's a lot of other pessimism going
around in the early 70s
people are having a crisis of um trust
and authority
there's a general feeling of paranoia
and nothing
nothing speaks to feelings of paranoia
like radiation because radiation
is invisible and it could be all around
you and you'll never know
the result was a backlash against
nuclear
further fueled by the release in 1979
of a film called the china syndrome
which vividly portrays an accident at a
nuclear power station
the thing about the china syndrome other
than it's pretty good sort of like
example of that sort of like 1970s
paranoid filmmaking
is that it comes out more or less at
exactly the same time as there is a
nuclear accident through my eye
[Music]
the two water pumps that help cool
reactor number two shut down
officials say some 50 to 60 thousand
gallons of radioactive water
escaped into the reactor building
this was followed by the infamous
meltdown at chernobyl in 1986
and then in 2011 a tsunami led to an
accident at a nuclear power station in
fukushima
japan each accident
stoked fears about nuclear power after
fukushima
nuclear had the lowest global public
support of all energy sources
even lower than coal
[Music]
but nuclear power is one of the safest
forms of energy production
although the official death toll linked
to fukushima stands at almost 600
all of these fatalities bar one were
attributed to the stress
of the evacuation had a full-scale
meltdown at fukushima
and that didn't kill people i caused a
huge bill for cleaning up but it didn't
kill people
so in normal operation and these days
even when breaking down
a well-regulated nuclear power plant is
not a dangerous object
compared to other forms of energy
production the death rate from nuclear
energy
is very low on average it kills one
person
every 14 years in fact in 2013
climatologists james hansen and pushka
korecha
calculated that the use of nuclear power
between 1971
and 2009 prevented the deaths of 1.84
million people
thanks to its air pollution benefits
the fear that nuclear plants emit
dangerous levels of radiation
is overblown the only accident which
released high levels of radiation and
caused significant harm to public health
was chernobyl but it was a not very good
nuclear plant being run in a terrible
way
people worry about radiation but in
general
nuclear power stations do not release
radiation
a more substantial concern centers on
nuclear fuel
nuclear power stations need nuclear fuel
and
normally that nuclear fuel has to be
something that's been enriched
now that enrichment process is also the
process that you use
to make nuclear weapons
[Music]
nuclear weapons can also be made by
extracting plutonium from spent nuclear
fuel
this means countries can use power
stations as a cover-up
for developing weaponry risking the
spread of atomic weapons
to nations not recognized as nuclear
weapon states
in the non-proliferation treaty
most people with nuclear power stations
are not proliferation risks
they either have nuclear weapons um or
clearly don't really want nuclear
weapons what you worry about is when you
have a
country that you're that is in an
unstable part of the world and starts
getting interested in nuclear technology
perhaps the most worrying example is
iran
since the 1980s western governments have
been concerned that iran will use its
uranium enrichment programme
for military purposes to tehran this is
a peaceful civilian enterprise
but some around the world fear it may
lead to the development of a nuclear
weapon
[Music]
but developing nuclear weapons from
civilian programs is difficult
reactors only need uranium enriched to
about four percent
nuclear weapons can need levels of
around 90
and while extracting plutonium is
slightly easier
any country planning to launch a new
nuclear power industry
will attract close attention from bodies
like the international atomic energy
[Music]
agency
but ultimately the reason nuclear power
is not used more widely
stems from one crucial factor it's
really expensive
nuclear power stations are very large
fairly complex
systems which you have to build very
precisely
they're huge construction projects which
drag out over time
and that drives up the cost
for nuclear reactors completed between
2016 and 2019
the median construction time was almost
17 years
the cost can be kept to some extent
contained if you make a lot of something
and that's to some extent the secret of
the success of the french program the
french
chose a specific design and made a lot
of it
the chinese are doing something similar
in america there was never any
standardization that's one of the
reasons
why the cost got completely out of
control in the 1970s
and that helps explain why the number of
active reactors around the world
has hardly changed since the 1980s
and a quarter of existing nuclear
reactors in advanced economies
are expected to close by 2025.
nuclear power has also become a less
attractive option
as renewables such as solar and wind
have fallen in cost
[Music]
but tackling climate change with just
renewables is much more challenging
it is a lot easier to decarbonize an
electricity system
if you have a certain amount of what's
often called
firm generating capacity that you can
rely on to be there
and nuclear supporters will tell you
that nuclear
is a very good example of that
[Music]
some advocates of nuclear power also
hope that a new approach
called advanced nuclear technology could
address the high cost
of nuclear energy this involves smaller
reactors which can be built off site
making them much cheaper and quicker to
construct
it would be a big investment to actually
build an experiment
and i'm not sure that it's the most
timely thing
i think that you know nuclear power
plants that are currently quite new will
probably keep running
a lot longer than i will but the idea
that we can have what used to be called
basically until fukushima
a nuclear renaissance that nuclear
renaissance hasn't happened
without a dramatic reduction in costs
it's unlikely
nuclear will ever reach the same heady
heights of the 1960s boom
perhaps if the environmentalists then
had known how powerful a threat
climate change would become the outcome
for nuclear
might have been very different i'm
oliver morton briefings editor at the
economist
to read our report on the lessons of
fukushima please click on the link
opposite
and if you've enjoyed this please
subscribe to our channel for more
you